the genesis really came from yo Kim and
his writing partner s convoy who wrote
the screenplay and I think that um just
a lot of ideas that they were you know
thinking about and sort of obsessing on
and they wrote the screenplay and when
Ron and I read it it it hit a lot of our
buttons and we just felt it was both a
very compelling screenplay filled with
ideas and also humanity and we responded
to the characters we responded to the
ideas in the script to strike a balance
between what is essentially a family
dynamic drama and the motivating element
of this which is a war photographer a
combat photographer how how did you
thread that needle which must have been
a moving needle well really Yoakam
thread was 12 threat to thread the
needle you know we were just really
taken with his earlier work reap reason
oslow august 31st and we just thought he
was a you know brilliant filmmaker and
when he wrote this script all those
ideas were there so has producers you
know you just try to somehow have it
come to fruition and get it made I must
say it's great to be here as producers
because with these blinding lights I can
only imagine the auditorium is totally
filled so thank you very much yes
supportive producers but you know that
art of we were just lucky that this
script existed and it was so rich with
ideas and you know Albert and I have
different interpretations of excuse me
some aspects of it it's just a film that
you know so many people take different
things away from it because it's in part
a a family story in part an
international story in part a character
story how I called it the other day and
I hope very favorably a trauma t because
there's drama there's drama and there's
comedy and it's really that mix and what
because it does have that Rashomon
sensibility that if you take a character
and take it all the way through you'll
come away seeing essentially a different
movie than someone who decides to commit
to a different character how did you
talked about some of the differences of
perception that each of you had what
perceptions did you bring to it and what
did you come away with well I mean for
me as a father of two boys more or less
the ages of these kids in the movie it
was quite an ordeal I and you know
really brought to mind you know how
difficult it is to be a parent
particularly under difficult
circumstances and how I you know as well
intended as you might be you might be
doing exactly the wrong thing and so my
heart really breaks for gabriel byrne in
this movie but really i think there's
something in all of the characters i
mean for those of us who work in film
and go away for long periods of time
leaving your family in that sense of
dislocation i mean it's nothing as
Extreme as what is about her Paris is
going through in this movie but you know
you can't help but be very taken with
the sense of when you're here you're not
there when you're there you're not here
you don't remember that you know you're
trying to stay up up with what's going
on with your family but you know how
difficult it is to kind of move in and
out of those worlds so there's a lot to
take from each of the characters I think
and yet it was the Isabella pair
character who seemed clearest about her
life and her role in her work and
everyone else around her the ripple
effects of that here we are eight nine
thousand miles from where she was doing
her work the ripple effects from people
who think it doesn't touch me because
I'm not anywhere near it yeah I take
something from that the impact of you
know the US and other countries and in
international war and the collateral
damage but you know even if that element
was not in the script or the movie just
the subjectivity of the way that we
perceive our lives and we're on kind of
a slippery boat where we're looking for
some anchor of meaning and and so when
those three guys are like in in in their
own way sometimes very inappropriately
from I guess most of our points of view
searching for a way to make sense out of
out of the trauma of the missing mother
wife but also just making sense of their
life as a whole in this you know it
seems like they're just left
of abandoned they're all orphans in a
way and so I think that's the most
powerful aspect of it to me was it hard
to get funding because I saw so many
logos there it was sort of like a
GoFundMe movie version somehow yeah one
step away from Kickstarter although it
was all international company show it's
kind of a joke were the only company
there without an animated logo yeah well
as the only company that didn't put
money in yeah how did that work yeah we
just went in but we didn't take any outs
yeah yeah no that's that's really true
you know there's so many different
sources Scandinavia France and a couple
US equity people but I don't know if you
count them there's like twenty seven
major pieces to make this financing work
yeah it's really crazy at the beginning
of the film with all those companies but
you know the the truth is the thing
that's amazing about it is it was a 13
million dollar movie which is kind of
amazing in and of itself you couldn't
get you know two or three million
dollars to make this movie in America
and of that all but a million and a half
was European grant money in various you
know forms of subsidies so I they
clearly recognized Yoakam tree Reza of
great cultural importance in Europe and
particularly in Scandinavia and they
support they support the films he makes
and yet the film is set in the United
States which had to be a very deliberate
choice it's not a European film in that
sense and you clearly were thinking of
an American audience as well no no very
very much so and he talks very
articulately about being influenced by
Arthur Miller and Woody Allen and all
that and then in turn talks about how
woody allen was influenced by birdman or
Arthur Miller by Ipsen and so there in
his view there's a very much a cultural
you know merging of sensibilities here
in what he's trying to do here when it
came to casting you obviously you had to
have a enough of a sense of ensemble
casting to make it a credible family how
did the casting decisions come about
well yoakum had these actors in mind I
mean it was an issue
other with a French accent and you know
father with an Irish accent and you know
how would that all gel and it was just
sort of one you know the idea was it's a
family that came together with those you
know international antecedents but that
you know except for discovering devon
druid those were really his wish list of
actors yeah and the thing that's
interesting to me about it and I think
very good is that um you know when you
live in New York or LA you meet so many
people from other places that have
families here but you rarely see that in
the movies so I mean I think it's
completely credible that in nyack new
york where they lived you know that
there is a French photographer and
there's a Irish aspiring actor who
becomes a schoolteacher and and there's
your families and and of course even
even before it get it got made it was
difficult and and nearly did not get
made was that just the funding issue
would get so close and then something
would fall apart yeah it just you know
the the year before we made it in
september-october in November of 2014
the the year before is just about to go
and it was a little bit short of money
in yo Keem just didn't want to
compromise on certain things that would
you know allow it to be made at that
budget so it was always you know it's
the kind of experience as a producer
that is really frustrating I mean Albert
and I kind of got a nice creative
participation but there were two other
producers Josh Astrakhan in New York and
and Thomas Robson and in in Scandinavia
where they had the headache of trying to
get all these pieces to stay together at
the same time and whenever you get 17 of
them three others would drop out so it
was really a puzzle that way yeah and we
we got involved seven or eight years ago
in this movie before any any of those
other producers did and tried to put
this film together cate blanchett at
that time we brought it to her and she
was attached to play Isabel and Jesse
was going to do it as well but then it
fell apart and Tomas got involved and
Josh got involved in
in some ways they really did a mazing
job of finally delivering this movie
because at first we were going to try
and make it through the American I kind
of indie a mini major system where like
Fox Searchlight or focus or somewhere
like that would finance it based on the
casting but when we weren't able to do
that it took a big effort of bringing
additional funds which they they did and
we all got together and made the movie
finally did the movie then necessarily
change over those seven or eight years
no I'm really not not not a lot I mean
we stayed with it because we believed in
him and and the script was so rich in
its ambiguity and you know its themes
and also we thought if we managed to
stick with it and get this made we get
to make three escaped as comedies as a
counterbalance how are those coming
along where we're going full steam you
know this is it's just such a great film
because you know Albert and I could talk
about it for hours of the way we and
other people interact with it and he was
showing the other night and and a guy
came up to me and he said well what's
that old man mean at the end and I said
well you know that's interesting that
subject to interpretation and cut me off
he said well you don't know what it
means either so it's the nothing in this
film has just one answer so many films
like this are seen by a broader American
audiences oh that's kind of a European
film how do you end up breaking that
mold and make this scene as an American
film because it's an American story well
you know it is a demanding film we you
know it's it's it's American film but
it's very complex I mean the last time
Albert and I got to sit up here and not
say anything was on Nebraska because we
had six or eight other people with us at
so got rid of all those yeah today yeah
well you hold the floor will make the
most of every acre self talk but you
know that kind of film which you know we
obviously very much I'm proud of but you
know it's an external narrative things
happen and you
the audience gets to you know kind of
react to these characters is their kind
of wobbling down the road here it's like
the cameras put inside people's heads
and you know they're seeing their life
as someone else might perceive it or as
it might happen or someone else would
narrate it that's really a complex film
I mean you really have to go to the
coffee house afterwards to sort it out
yeah like that that scene for instance
in the classroom when when the the girl
that he the young characters kind of
fixated on is stumbling through her
reading and then all of a sudden starts
to very very eloquently recount what
happened to his mother as he's imagining
it I mean and then and then later as
they're walking on the street it's
almost as if he's imagining a novel that
he's written in the future narrated
heroically by her about this you know
great moment in his life so it's pretty
you got to stay on your toes here yeah
so won't you please thank Ron York
salford thank you